The equation of the vertical line that goes through the point negative 5 6 is x
equals negative five. What do we know about vertical lines? We know that
vertical lines look like this. We know that vertical lines have undefined slope,
and we also know that the equation of a vertical line is always going to be x
equals a constant. Since this vertical line goes through the point Negative 5,
6. We know that no matter what value y is, x is always going to remain at
negative 5. So, the equation of the vertical line through the point negative 5,
6 is X equals negative 5. For the second problem, the equation of the horizontal
line that goes to the point negative 5, 6 is Y equals 6. What do we know about
horizontal lines? We know they go left to right, or right to left. We know that
the slope is 0, and we know their equation looks like y equals a constant. Now
if we know that this horizontal line goes to the point negative 5,6, if I plot
the point negative 5,6 on this horizontal line what I notice is no matter what
value x is, y is always going to be 6. So I get the equation y equals 6. If you
got these answers right, great work.